nuevo tiroteo en eeuu horas de
incertidumbre en boulder colorado
terminaron con las malas noticias que
muchos esperaban
tuvimos un incidente trágico el día de
hoy perdimos muchas vidas tenemos
múltiples víctimas cuya moto por aquí
en esencia en este incidente tengo que
mencionar que uno de nuestros policías
perdió la vida
el policía fallecido fue el primero en
llegar al lugar de los hechos un
supermercado en la periferia de la
ciudad donde a las tres de la tarde se
reportó la presencia de un tirador
activo los testigos describieron una
situación caótica y aterradora
escuché un estruendo y pensé fue un poco
extraño y no sabía si era un disparo o
algo así pero pasaron como tres segundos
antes de escuchar otro un sonido como
bang bang e inmediatamente corrí hacia
ella y le dije tenemos que salir de aquí
empuje la puerta de emergencia para
abrirla
y disparó hacia nosotros pudimos
sentirlo y seguimos corriendo
simplemente corrimos y había alguien
tirado en el camino y traté de correr
hacia él y nicolás me hallo y me dijo
que teníamos que irnos y simplemente
corrimos y nos escondimos detrás del
edificio
la policía hirió y capturó al presunto
autor del ataque en el mismo
supermercado bajo custodia recibió
cuidados médicos este tiroteo ocurre
solo una semana después de otro ataque
en georgia que dejó ocho víctimas
mortales